Democrats vote tomorrow in South
Carolina's primary where Joe Biden now
appears to be the heavy favorite the
newest poll shows the former vice
president with 36 percent support a
substantial lead in South Carolina
senator Bernie Sanders the Democrats
national front runner is second with 16
percent followed by billionaire
businessman Tom Styer with 15 percent Ed
O'Keefe is in Columbia South Carolina
and what are the candidates up to this
morning well Anthony good morning we
tallied it up and they're holding at
least 16 events across this state today
but with a Biden win seemingly likely
the other contenders are now fanning out
across the country trying to visit those
14 states casting ballots on Tuesday
this nation isn't looking for a
revolution it's looking for results
former Vice President Joe Biden is
poised to win his first contest of the
2020 campaign as he travels through
South Carolina
he's touting a familiar talking point
his close work with former President
Obama vowing to build on the Affordable
Care Act
I'm not running to destroy Bachmann
Barack Obama's signature legislative
achievement but his lead here isn't
stopping opponents from raising concerns
about whether he has what it takes to go
the distance Joe Biden is a good friend
of mine I don't Joe for many years he is
a decent guy but I don't believe that
Joe can beat Trump when people learn
that he voted for the war in Iraq as
candidates prepare for Super Tuesday
next week former mayor Pete Buddha judge
believes he can emerge as the best
alternative for Bernie Sanders we've got
the most votes and the most delegates of
any candidate besides senator Sanders
I'm the only one who's beaten him
anywhere on the trail Democratic
contenders are speaking out more
frequently about the coronavirus they
fault President Trump for not doing more
to prepare the country thank you he's
not leading he's reacting much much too
late and his son confidence really does
put us all at risk I believe this has
been a dangerously incompetent response
to a global pandemic and this is exactly
my point about him he's actually
incompetent in a statement Sanders said
that the administration must stop
releasing misleading unscientific and
false information about whether the
virus can be controlled
and senator Elizabeth Warren introduced
a bill that would divert all money
budgeted to build a us-mexico border
wall to instead fight the virus even as
the administration works to fight
coronavirus the president will be here
in South Carolina today to hold a
campaign rally in North Charleston Tony
wherever the Democrats are he likes to
follow and thank you very much